[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new tip 2019 interview here at the
supper suite we are talking to some of
the filmmakers behind the movie Mosel
guys thank you so much for your time
today I was telling you before I cannot
wait to catch your movie and it's a very
big deal for you because this is a
feature directorial debut so first off
why make this story your first feature
and also can you give everybody a brief
synopsis of what the movie is about
because most people out there will not
have heard of it sure sure there I can
kind of answer them both at once it was
an article that was sent to me that Luke
mogensen wrote for The New Yorker about
this group of people who up until I read
that article I didn't know existed and
they're remarkable and it's about this
in the Navy SWAT team the only unit that
hasn't retreated in the fight against
Isis in Mosul and I was struck by how
brutal the existence is how they make it
work how they're they kind of live their
lives minute by minute the criteria to
get on the SWAT team itself is is fairly
brutal you have to have lost somebody to
Isis or been wounded by them and most
every member of the SWAT team claims
both and so I just before I even finish
the article I was kind of in my gut knew
that I certainly wanted to write it
because that's how it was sent to me but
I would write it if I could also direct
it because I just you know I it struck
me there's a great opportunity here for
a larger audience to feel the same way
about these people after watching a
movie that I felt after reading the
article about them and there's a you
know it hit this thing that I look for
and everything that we are so much more
alike than we are different you know
regardless of language the version of
God we worship where were born what
continent were living
decent human beings everywhere wants
some of the same fundamental things for
the people they love so I yeah like I
said within the first few pages I was
desperate to do it because it grabbed
those those things in me that I'm always
looking for in a project a little bit
about the audition process now and
looping these to your film because I was
also obviously reading up and an all
Arabic casts using the dialect as well
it sounds like oh it could be a big
challenge for you when you speak the
language but it also sounds like you
guys made the right decision
yeah without a doubt I and and initially
I think it struck a lot of people as a
huge challenge
I think it's the only way to do a movie
like this so we went truly all around
the world looking for this talent that
we have in the cast we couldn't get
anyone directly out of Iraq because we
pre-production is right when the travel
ban madness was happening in the United
States so everything was kind of frozen
we couldn't get them out of Iraq and I
think if we could have getting them into
Morocco was a months-long proposition so
we went everywhere Adam is from France
he's Tunisian Sohail was born and raised
in Baghdad but now lives in Albuquerque
New Mexico was a refugee and made it to
the United States we have a kid from
Detroit we have five from Amman Jordan
we had people from Egypt from Iraq and
it was just a question of can we in this
diaspora can we find you know 12 14
really great people for the SWAT team
and and I think we did that and it was
literally Seraphin and Lara Tala and
Amman Jordan it was a global effort and
I think they they did a spectacular job
I cannot wait to see everybody in action
in this movie Sohail I was reading a
little bit about
your career overall and just like the
highs making it in America what was it
like having this script in this
opportunity cross your path at this
point in your career thank you for
everything I think it's really is a good
opportunity for us like in Arab actors
and this is I think it's the first time
that's happening and in Hollywood they
they have a movie for they did it all in
Arabic language and they choose like all
the Arabic characters Thailand this is
the first time having I think like that
and it was really great a great thing
for us and not not just for us it's for
all the Arabic actors too
that's what I think it's I think it's a
great and Mathew oh he did a great job
in this movie and every everybody did a
great job all the production all the
producers everybody did the hard work
for this movie to make them successful
if you had a name one person on the crew
of this movie that made a difference in
your day that you might not have
expected who would it be
it could be anyone from a PA to someone
at craft service anything at all good I
can't say any name but I say all of them
all of them when I saw the movie I say
oh my god everybody did a great job
like from the beginning the first thing
when they Casson us I think after that
we have the boot camp for three weeks
three weeks right my three weeks three
weeks boot camp it was great they helped
us a lot to do our job like when we
shooting like the movement how we can
use the weapons how we can clean the
rooms cross the street everything it's
great it's great everybody like very
helpful I love hearing that Adam I was
reading that a whole lot of people
auditioned for this role
you're the one who scores it how do you
celebrate after you find out you got the
gig how did I celebrate yeah oh well I
was language lessons I just I just
started to work in just after so it was
a both emotion you know like I'm super
happy and excited and at the same time I
said here we go now you know just get
into it so it was yeah I was a blast I
was super happy now let's make Matthew
blush little right now what is it about
him as an actor's director that makes
him someone special oh where do I start
first of all I have to say that as a as
Arabs and from French era but I grew up
with the Arab culture first of all I was
choked by everything he knew he knew
more then most of us are on on details
the the work he did first of all was
such a gigantic work on and I I can I
can tell you I know a lot of Arabs that
didn't know everything he knew and the
details he knew the hard work was
extraordinary so first of all it's it's
a it's blast to begin working and then I
mean artistically with just he's just I
mean he got a great personality he's
super intelligent so we don't need to
talk a lot he really quickly understand
what we want to do he's a super open to
ideas and in the same time he knows what
when to say no which is really important
I think so you can you know where you're
going so I mean just I don't want to
make him but he's literally intelligent
humble hard worker and no I mean it was
just great great great he never never
never yelling than to sit now that's a
great thing which is something being a
Carnahan that I was
sounds like an extremely ambitious
project on so many levels if you had to
isolate one particular scene where
you're like I don't know if we could
pull this off and then you did and it
just felt super great with that scene
Bay I think the there's a there's kind
of a penultimate attack on a base that
was huge and initially when we started
kind of planning it I thought yeah it
was it was it's over the course of
several days it's a coordinated assault
where the team splits in two and I that
one was daunting but I think thankfully
it came at the end of the shoot so I
kind of by the time we got there I think
I I knew much more what I was actually
doing and again these guys they don't
need to be told more than once and we
would just run through it until
everybody felt good
we had great kind of technical advice on
hand at all times to make this look I
mean my thought going in is and it kills
me that I keep you know hearing people
call it an action movie it's an action
movie insofar as like we wanted to get
that exactly right
mirroring what's in the article and what
I've heard directly from some of the
members of the SWAT team and other
people who've been in combat I I wanted
it to be as frenetic and as terrifying
as that but yeah III do think that that
scene initially daunting I think we we
covered it really well it might be one
of my favorite scenes in the movie but
that that's the one that sticks out as
being kind of the most daunting yeah I
cannot wait to see all of this thank you
guys so much for your time today
thank you keep an eye out for it guys I
can't wait to catch moesel myself and
you should keep an eye out for it too as
always we must thank our special sponsor
for making all these interviews happen
it is Nordstrom Canada thank you to you
guys do not leave this video without
liking and
sharing it and stay tuned because we're
gonna have more from tip 2019 coming
your way soon